Dunkle materie das wohl größte rätsel der physik irgend etwas. Dunkles muss es da draußen geben aber experimentell
Konnte die dunkle materie bisher nicht bewiesen werden am kernforschungszentrum cern hofft man täglich auf eine bahnbrechende entdeckung
Jetzt hat die physik der dunklen materie einen tag gewidmet den tag der dunkle materie am 31 oktober
Halloween wie dunkle materie jeden von uns auf schritt und tritt
begleitet wie gefährlich sie wirklich ist und vieles mehr zudem vielleicht spannendsten rätsel der wissenschaft
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Lavigne wird jetzt noch unheimlicher teilchen physiker und physikerinnen weltweit haben sich
Im netzwerk interactions dot org zusammengetan und den tag der dunklen materie auf ende oktober
gelegt der grund in diesem, zeitraum werden in vielen ländern
gruselige unheimliche feste gefeiert bei denen es um geister und
Übernatürliches geht wie halloween wie passend jetzt wird daran erinnert dass das universum zum größten teil dunkel und
unheimliches dunkle materie macht etwa 85 prozent der materie unseres ganzen universums
Aus sie beeinflusst wohl die ausbreitung von licht strahlen und auch die rotation von galaxien
teilchenphysiker und physikerin vermuten dass dunkle materie, aus elementarteilchen besteht die bislang noch
unentdeckt sind und die suche danach läuft auf hochtouren wir haben hier ja schon beispielsweise
öfter über die großen experimente an
gigantischen
Teilchenbeschleuniger wie dem large hadron collider am genfer cern berichtet. Um die verborgenen teilchen der dunklen materie
aufzuspüren sie endlich zu entdecken und sie experimentell zu beweisen das wäre wirklich eine riesige sensation
dass sie existieren muss dafür sind physikerinnen und physiker überzeugt denn das zeigen zum beispiel berechnung der rotationsgeschwindigkeit
von galaxien oder
Gravitations effekte, im weltall ja vieles was wir
Im universum beobachten lässt sich nicht mit der bislang bekannten material ein beispiel dazu
Licht wird sehr viel stärker abgelenkt wenn es an galaxien vorbeifliegt als man es erwarten würde es muss also etwas
geben das das licht an die dunkle materie eben nach gängigen erklärt modellen müssten sterne dagegen eigentlich aus ihren galaxien
herausgeschleudert werden weil sie sich so schnell bewegen
Forschungsteams weltweit vermuten dass dunkle materie sie quasi festhält manchmal wird sie auch als eine art klebstoff
bezeichnet der galaxien zusammenhält der teilchenbeschleuniger
Lhc am cern abend die bedingungen kurz nach dem urknall nach mit beinahe lichtgeschwindigkeit
werden zwei protonenstrahlen in
entgegengesetzter richtung aufeinander gejagt wenn sie aufeinandertreffen wird kollisionsenergie frei ihre energiedichte ist
gigantisch die dadurch entstandene material könnte unbekannte teilchen enthalten
So die hoffnung der forschungsteams die idee dahinter ist ganz einfach die energie die bei der protonen kollisionen entsteht muss
Derjenigen energie entsprechen die anfangs rein gesteckt wurde und das ist messbar
Messbar genauso wie die bekannten teilchen heißt also
Im umkehrschluss wenn alle bekannten teilchen gemessen wurden und energie fehlt liefe dies auf ein
unsichtbares teilchen eben der dunkle materie schließen erst wenn wir die dunkle materie verstehen
Können viele wir vielleicht besser verstehen wie das universum entstanden ist und sich entwickelt hat
Ihre entdeckung wäre wirklich eine riesige sensation
vergleichbar mit der entdeckung der gravitationswellen auch noch viel größer zudem
begleitet dunkle materie jeden von uns so vermuten physikerinnen und physiker auch wenn man sich merken denn sie
Ist quasi überall in jedem zimmer dieser welt auch hier wenn auch nur in einer sehr geringen menge
es gibt schätzungen nach denen ihre menge ungefähr der masse eines einzelnen protons pro
Kubikmeter entspricht also hier werden vielleicht nutzen aber wie gefährlich kann als die dunkle materie er kennt alle diese
katastrophalen szenarien in denen schwarze löcher die erde verschlucken aber die cern
forschungsteam sind sich ganz sicher dass das mehr als abwegig ist falls durch
teilchenbeschleuniger schwarze löcher entstehen würden würden sie in bruchteilen von nanosekunden zerfallen und hätten zudem
Weniger anziehungskraft als ein billionstel eines staub kurz aber das bringt uns noch auf eine weitere these
Besteht die dunkle materie vielleicht aus schwarzen löchern das video dazu gibt es hier
Und wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
Ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht dem genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst sie auch kein video und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran